[Musik]
es ist alles anders in diesen corona
zeiten das spürt man und das sieht man
auch in unserem falle deutlich denn wir
verzichten auf unser publikum und auch
auf unserem tisch und mindestabstände
einzuhalten
wir bei phoenix haben viele kollegen ins
home office geschickt interne
kommunikation findet vor allem per
telefon oder online statt dienstreisen
workshops und ähnliches alles wurde
abgesagt und ist es wichtig dass wir in
der lage sind sie zu informieren vor
allem mit pressekonferenzen aber auch
mit unserem gesprächssendungen um eine
einordnung zu bieten aber auch unsere
heutige sendung dreht sich deshalb um
das virus wir wollen versuchen zu
ergründen welche kollektiven wirkungen
das virus hat wie es unser zusammenleben
prägt und verändert und damit herzlich
willkommen bei unter den linden und ich
begrüße sehr herzlich bei uns professor
harald welzer soziologe und
sozialpsychologe herzlich willkommen an
sie und konstantin coole den
innenpolitischen sprecher der fdp
fraktion im deutschen bundestag herzlich
willkommen an sie beide gewässer der
korona virus hat deutschland innerhalb
von kurzer zeit ziemlich verändert und
zwar ziemlich drastisch hat es in ihrer
wahrnehmung jemals so eine drastische
veränderung in so kurzer zeit gegeben
und er ja in der dimension das jetzt
dass das keine erscheinung bis die
irgendwie ein bestimmtes segment oder
ein bereich nur betrifft hat es so was
tatsächlich noch nicht gegeben also alle
müssen sich in irgendeiner weise neue
verhalten zu diesem gesamtgeschehen und
da wäre mir nichts vergleichbares
irgendwie bekannt
ja also man hat bei nine eleven
natürlich eine große
sicherheitsproblematik eine tiefe
verunsicherung bei der finanzkrise hat
man auf der ebene der finanziellen
absicherung oder der ganzen dimension
der der weiteren bankenfinanzierung oder
sowas und alle segmente
aber hier haben wir gewissermaßen eine
totale betroffenheit und das ist neu
sie haben neulich in einem interview
gesagt wir sind in einer situation der
etwas geschehen ist dass fast alle
routine und den normalbetrieb
unterbricht was bedeutet das denn und
was was für lehren sie wieder raus das
mit den lehrern das ist mir glaube ich
noch diskutieren aber zunächst mal der
interessante fall
das ist man an so einem ereignis sehen
kann dass wir ja prinzipiell mit
normalität erwartungen durchs leben
laufen deshalb kann man urlauber buchen
deshalb kann man renten verträge
abschließen
wir gehen ja bei jeder geschichte die
wir machen immer davon aus dass ist in
den nächsten drei monaten noch genau so
dass im nächsten drei jahren noch
genauso ist die nächsten 30 jahren noch
genauso oder wenn man sich über die
ausbildung der kinder gedanken macht und
so ist immer zu grunde liegen das geht
alles so weiter
und wenn wir solche solche
unterbrechungen ereignisse haben die
eben diese normalität radikal
unterbrechen dann sind diese erwartungen
natürlich außer kraft gesetzt und man
steht erstmal gewissermaßen ohne
drehbuch da was heißt das jetzt ja und
das macht eigentlich die wie soll man
sagen dass der spektakuläre dieser
situation aus und welche lehren man
daraus ziehen kann also ich würde jetzt
erst mal ganz vorsichtig nur sagen die
alte lehre ist dass immer alles anders
sein kann also wir haben dann immer
solche ereignisse alle paar jahrzehnte
oder so was die eben zeigen menschliches
leben das leben hofft der erde
beinhaltet unerwartet bahre ereignisse
und dementsprechend auch unterbrechung
von unseren normalen routine und
erwartungen und das kann man erst mal
zunächst mal wieder lernen hier an
dieser stelle hercules und drastische
veränderungen die unser tägliches leben
auch betreffen der welt gerade
gesprochen urlaubsreisen sind so gar
nicht mehr möglich
die grenzen sind zwei weise zu geschäfte
sollen bald schließen es gibt viele
dinge schulen sind geschlossen kitas
sind geschlossen viele dinge die unser
tägliches leben radikal verändert haben
wie würden sie sagen reagiert die
bevölkerung darf ich glaube dass wir
sehr unterschiedliche reaktionen der
bevölkerung beobachten können auf der
einen seite gibt es eine große menge an
menschen die sehr gut informiert durch
die republik läuft und sich auf
bestimmte maßnahmen einstellt die sich
viel zu hause befinden die auch die
möglichkeit haben von zu hause aus zu
arbeiten sogar von ihrem arbeitgeber und
da kann man sehr viel
verantwortungsbewusstsein beobachten auf
der anderen seite gibt es einmal sehr
viele menschen gibt es nicht können es
gibt menschen die in pflegeberufen tätig
sind die in krankenhäusern tätig sind
die
in bereichen tätig sind die für das
öffentliche leben ganz wichtig sind und
für diesen solcher einschränkungen heute
gar nicht möglich die müssen darauf
achten dass bestimmte hygienemaßnahmen
eingehalten werden aber es ist sehr
schwierig für die und deswegen würde ich
sagen kommt es sehr stark darauf an über
welche menschen wie hier sprechen und
leider kann man auch beobachten dass
bestimmte informationen gerade was die
vermeidung sozialer kontakte angeht noch
nicht überall angekommen sind und ich
würde mir wünschen dass das noch von
mehr menschen konsequent durchgezogen
wird und bestimmte dinge jetzt
unterlassen werden sind sie sagen es ist
eher eine besondere aktion oder durchaus
auch panische reaktion
also ich würde sagen die reaktion
unterscheidet sich zunächst einmal
insofern lebens unrecht herr professor
jetzt ja von allem was wir gesehen haben
oder seen mit blick auf andere tragische
ereignisse oder vorkommnisse im bereich
der inneren sicherheit im bereich der
öffentlichkeit wir können ganz oft
beobachten dass nach terroristischen
anschlägen wie beispielsweise in hanau
oder auch nach dem anschlag am berliner
breitscheidplatz wellen der öffentlichen
solidarität in die öffentlichkeit
getragen werden also nach dem motto wir
lassen uns unser öffentliches leben
nicht kaputtmachen und wir setzen ein
zeichen gegen diese form des terrorismus
und dass das in dem fall einer pandemie
im fall einer eines als virus kompletten
falsche reaktion ist das stellt glaube
ich viele menschen vor eine situation
die so nicht kennen und insofern erlebe
ich viele menschen als zögerlich als
abwertend als fragen und es werden sehr
viele fragezeichen gemacht an die
handlungsfähigkeit der politik an
wissenschaftlichen input und an unser
öffentliches leben und insofern gilt
auch hier dass die reaktionen sehr
unterschiedlich sind
um solchen fall werden ja durchaus auch
die freiheitsrechte des einzelnen
geschnitten das heißt wir haben sie eben
schon diskutiert das geht auch richtig
an das an die freiheitlichen rechte des
einzelnen heran
die bürger nehmen das ja doch eher hin
oder würden sie sagen es gibt dagegen
auch auf lähmungen oder leute die sich
das bislang noch nichts in der art
beobachten können
ich finde dass die leute sich eigentlich
relativ wie soll man sagen unaufgeregt
verhalten wenn man jetzt von den
berühmten klopapier hamsterkäufen
absieht die man wahrscheinlich
psychoanalytisch interpretieren muss
aber generell ist es ja so nach meinem
alltags eindruck dass die leute doch
relativ gelassen besonnen also gelassen
nicht besonnen mit der situation umgehen
und wie sie eben schon gesagt haben das
interessante ist ja man weiß ja nicht so
richtig und diese ist man weiß ja nicht
so richtig erzeugt im augenblick keine
panik sondern eher ein abwartendes er
beruhigt das verhalten also von vorn ist
ja kein aktionismus auf seiten der
bürgerinnen und bürger
und das ist eigentlich eine ganz
interessante geschichte seien erstaunt
sie das denn ich meine wir haben die
letzten monate jahre davon gesprochen
dass unsere gesellschaft immer stärker
zerfällt fragmentiert dass viele gruppen
ganz anders unterwegs sind der
zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft auch
wirklich fehlt aber hier scheint ja
jetzt eine wie sie sagen eine
besonderheit da zu sein die auch so ein
stück weit zusammen führt ja was eine
interessante interessantes thema dass
sie das jetzt hier in diesem
zusammenhang sagen ich habe nie der
erzählung angehangen dass wir eine
gespaltene gesellschaft haben und das
alles erodiert ist wir haben phänomene
von rechtsextremismus und rechts
nationalismus und wir haben
entsprechende wahlergebnisse
trotzdem ist ja die weit weit weit
überwiegende mehrheit in der
bundesrepublik sozusagen noch nicht von
sinnen gewesen und hat ja immer treu und
brav auch demokratische parteien gewählt
und verhält sich ja im alltag auch nicht
irgendwie auffällig also insofern haben
wir vielleicht sogar eine korrektur dass
man dieses was sich verändert hat
politisch auch an die stelle wieder
zurück rückt wo es hingehört dass wir
ein problem an den rändern haben aber
vielleicht können wir anders darüber
diskutieren wie wir sozusagen die
mehrheit der gesellschaft betrachten
auch anhand dieses ereignisses und dass
die mehrheit der gesellschaft jetzt auch
wirklich zusammenstehen soll das hat die
bundeskanzlerin neulich in ihrer
pressekonferenz noch mal gesagt nach
seinem ganz normal wir sind also in
einer situation in der wir vieles noch
nicht wissen
und das was wir wissen müssen wir sehr
ernst nehmen wir müssen alle kräfte
einsetzen wir müssen alle notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreifen das gilt für die
bundesregierung das gilt für alle
politisch verantwortlichen aber es gilt
auch für die bürgerinnen und bürger die
83 millionen menschen die in unserem
land leben
denn es geht um den schutz gerade auch
älterer menschen menschen mit
vorerkrankungen sogenannter vulnerable
gruppen wie man heute sagt und da sind
unsere solidarität unsere vernunft unser
herz füreinander schon auf eine probe
gestellt von der ich mir wünsche dass
wir diese probe auch bestehen herr
kohler die bundeskanzlerin forderte
solidarität ein vor allen dingen um das
risiko für die schwächeren für die
älteren für die kranken zu minimieren
zeigt sich in diesen krisenzeiten
tatsächlich auch so ein gemeinsames des
individuums oder gibt es auch den
egoismus ich sag mal der jungen leute
die dann doch ganz gerne party machen
und darauf eigentlich auch nicht
verzichten wollen also ich glaube wir
können schon beobachten dass diese
botschaften der bundeskanzlerin der
wissenschaft in breiten teilen der
bevölkerung ankommen ich teile auch
nicht diesen pessimismus mancher die
sagen also insbesondere bei jungen
menschen können wir eine besonders
verantwortungsloses verhalten beobachten
ich glaube wir müssen uns durchweg durch
die gesamte gesellschaft jeder einzelne
fragen was kann man in einer solchen
situation tun und vor allen dingen sind
ja staatliche maßnahmen die jetzt
angeordnet worden sind gar nicht
geeignet als einzige die
ansteckungskette zu verringern das
risiko zu verringern das gute beispiel
sind dafür die verordneten
grenzkontrollen die jetzt beginnen
werden oder jetzt begonnen haben wir
können sehen dass natürlich unnötiges
reisen durch grenzkontrollen verhindert
werden kann aber unnötiges reisen im
inland da können sie noch so viele
grenzkontrollen machen dass er kann auch
weiterhin stattfinden und da ist eben
jeder einzelne gefragt also es kommt auf
den gemeinsinn des individuums an dieser
gemeinsinn des individuums kann nicht
staatlich verordnet werden er ist da er
muss unterstützt werden und man kann an
ihn appellieren und so was zu tun als
wissenschaft und als politik das finde
ich absolut richtig
wir sind eigentlich jeden tag auch mit
medizinischen lager bewertungen
konfrontiert es gibt täglich
pressekonferenzen des
robert-koch-instituts wir hören
virologen epidemiologen die uns täglich
erklären was das mit dem virus auf sich
hat das ist ja für viele vielleicht auch
nicht immer ganz verständlich und es
ändert sich fast täglich inwiefern
glauben sie verängstigt dass oder
verunsichert dass die leute also ich
glaube dass zunächst mal eine
verunsicherung dadurch entstanden war
dass viele leute keine relation
herstellen konnten zwischen den geringen
fallzahlen und den flächendeckenden
maßnahmen also das worüber jetzt alle
sprechen es geht um die verlangsamung
die abflachung der der zunahme
das hat sich jetzt rumgesprochen aber
das wurde zu anfang nicht kommuniziert
und insofern haben natürlich leute
gerätselt wie jetzt ja also wir haben
influenza tote in einer viel größeren
zahl und so weiter und so weiter warum
jetzt das und nachdem sich das jetzt
aber glaube ich einigermaßen geklärt hat
und man grundlegend das prinzip
verstanden hat dass es um den schutz der
risikogruppen geht und dass man den
darüber herstellt dass man den prozess
versucht zu strecken zu verlangsamen
da sehen die leute schon irgendwie ein
na ja gut dann muss man das halt so
machen
ja und es ist eben noch mal an den
anfang zurück es ist kein abstraktes
geschehen bei vielen anderen krisen
ereignissen ist man relativ distanziert
falls man nicht direkt zu den opfern
zählt oder sowas ja das sind ja vieles
ist auch mediales ereignis was dann in
irgendeiner weise eine besondere
betroffenheit auslöst aber hier ist ja
in gewisser weise jeder jede betroffen
ja also der umstand dass man jetzt nicht
mehr sein seine angehörigen in einem
seniorenheim besuchen darf das ist neu
aber es ist natürlich eine starke
betroffenheit oder was machen die kinder
wenn sie nicht zur schule gehen usw
das sind ja auch nicht nur positive
betroffenheiten dass man näher
zusammenrückt näher zusammenrückt ist ja
auch für viele negative betroffenheit
weil man gar nicht so miteinander
umgehen
ja sie haben dass das ding mit den
entscheidungs raten nach urlaub und
weihnachten weil die menschen nicht
gelernt haben miteinander so lange
wirklich konfrontiert zu sein jetzt
haben sie die situation noch einmal
verdichtet die kinder sind auch noch zu
hause die ist ganze alltags arrangement
ist überhaupt nicht darauf ausgerichtet
dass man so viel zeit miteinander
verbringen also das ist nicht ganz ohne
da würden wir wahrscheinlich noch viele
konflikte sie neugierig sind sie denn da
als sozial als soziologe und sozial
ach ja das ist ja das ist ja immer eine
paarung zwischen neugier und in gewisser
weise natürlich auch dem wunsch des möge
jetzt also eine positive lernerfahrung
sein
also wenn wir haben ja nur unerwartet
erwartbare situation und das was jetzt
passiert ist für alle gleichermaßen
eigentlich eine lernen geschichte weil
man das so noch nicht kannte
und das ist natürlich interessant was
kommt denn bei der lern geschichte am
ende raus und wenn das ganze jetzt keine
ahnung ein paar monate dauert so als
gesamtzusammenhang kehrt man wieder in
den ursprungszustand zurück oder hat das
eine tiefenwirkung darauf dass man
mensch wir haben noch irgendwie ganz
tolle sachen zusammen gemacht wird oder
sogar warum sollen wir denn jetzt wieder
eine kreuzfahrt buchen oder sowas in der
art ja es kann ja wirkung haben
aber die können wir zum gegebenen
zeitpunkt überhaupt man nicht absehen
der coole wie beurteilen sie denn das
krisenmanagement der bundesregierung
also ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig sich
zu vergegenwärtigen dass die meisten
politiker die meisten manager menschen
die verantwortung tragen in vereinen
verbänden unternehmen momentan versuchen
auf der basis von fakten die richtigen
entscheidungen zu treffen und ich glaube
was heutzutage neu ist im vergleich zu
vorherigen pandemien oder solchen
geschehen ist dass alle bürgerinnen und
bürger am internet direkt teilhaben
können an wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen und sich natürlich fragen
warum wird auf der grundlage dieser
erkenntnisse oder dieses
wissenschaftlichen inputs nicht diese
entscheidung getroffen und dann
entstehen natürlich erwartungen an die
politik die auch noch weiter getragen
werden durch die rolle des journalismus
die dieser wahrnimmt und dann fragt man
entscheidet politik eigentlich das
richtige und
muss sagen ich bin zu früh auch als
oppositionsabgeordneter jetzt zu sagen
alles was der regierung da gemacht hat
ist auf jeden fall falsch oder richtig
das muss man abwarten das muss man sich
anschauen
ich bin froh dass wir an
unterschiedlichen stellen
gesundheitsminister innenminister
ministerinnen unterschiedlicher couleur
haben die jetzt sich den nötigen
wissenschaftlichen entbot holen und
handeln was man daraus für konsequenzen
zieht beispielsweise wie es mit dem
föderalismus weitergeht beim
katastrophenschutz beispielsweise was
die aufstellung unseres
gesundheitssystems anschaut das muss man
sich angucken mit kühlem kopf wenn diese
krise vorüber ist aber jetzt sozusagen
anzufangen die politischen
schlussfolgerungen das fänd ich falsch
das klingt so als wäre da eine gewisse
föderalismus kritik bei ihnen raus zu
hören
also ich bin der auffassung dass wir im
bereich der inneren sicherheit schon
lange ein problem mit dem föderalismus
haben wir haben nach dem
untersuchungsausschuss zum sogenannten
nationalsozialistischen untergrund zu
den vielen die es gegeben hat in den
ländern auf bundesebene wir haben jetzt
den untersuchungsausschuss zum thema
alles andere breitscheidplatz nicht die
nötigen schlussfolgerungen gezogen im
bereich des föderalismus wir können
jetzt beobachten dass wir ein sehr stark
dezentral organisiert das
gesundheitswesen haben da geht es gar
nicht um die länder sondern um
gesundheitsämter mit einem regionalen
schwerpunkt das hat massive nachteile es
kann aber auch massive vorteile haben
weil man viel schneller vor ort auf die
gegebenheiten reagieren kann und nicht
erst auf eine order warten muss also es
gibt vor und nachteile
und ich finde nicht dass es auch nicht
wenn man der opposition angehört jetzt
einem gut ansteht zu sagen ich hab die
einen hier eine die allein selig
machende antwort wir müssen uns angucken
wie hat das funktioniert aber der
föderalismus ist auch im bereich des
bevölkerungsschutzes nicht sakrosankt
sondern man kann da aussagen auf der
anderen seite wenn man sieht dass in
mecklenburg vorpommern die fallzahlen um
quasi inexistent sind in heinsberg in
nordrhein westfalen aber dann
entsprechend hoch ist es dann nicht
richtig auch unterschiedlich zu
reagieren absolut und ich glaube dass
der föderalismus immer ein lädt ihn
abschaffen zu wollen die bürgerinnen und
bürger sind in deutschland immer sehr
schnell dabei zu applaudieren dann ihn
ein politiker verspricht also wenn ihr
nicht wählt dann schaffe ich den
föderalismus ab bei der inneren
sicherheit beim bildungssystem das kann
doch nicht sein dass wir 60
unterschiedliche systeme an und dann
wird geklatscht und an das anders
gut aber ganz so einfach ist es eben ich
werde ein föderales land schon immer
sind und weil wir diesen föderalismus in
der verfassung festgeschrieben haben aus
gutem grund weil er ermöglicht auf
unterschiedliche situationen
unterschiedlich zu reagieren und weil
wir gerade im bereich bevölkerungsschutz
und katastrophenhilfe beispielsweise
auch ein system haben was denken sie nur
an thw denken sie an das rote kreuz die
johanniter was sehr stark auf ehrenamt
auf ehrenamtlichem engagement beruht
also da muss man sehr stark darauf
achten dass man nicht zu einfache
lösungen anbietet aber auch im bereich
gesundheitssystem kann man natürlich
über den föderalismus nachdenken und das
sollte man mit kühlem kopf tun wenn
diese krise vorüber ist er weiter wir
haben schon darüber gesprochen über das
thema angst dass die menschen eigentlich
durchaus besonnen reagieren aber
nichtsdestotrotz es gibt ja auch viele
menschen die einfach angst haben angst
deshalb weil ist ein drohender oder
tatsächlicher treffer lust ist viele
haben den eindruck die kontrolle der del
haben wir uns ja jetzt entzogen weil wir
nicht wissen was auf uns zukommt wenn
die sache nicht mehr beherrschbar ist
dann bekommen wir eben einfach angst wie
irrational ist denn das ist rational
also meine unterscheidet ja es ist im
grunde seit sigmund freud zwischen real
angst und neurotische angst und wir
haben viele ängste die keinen rationalen
grund haben also wenn man zum beispiel
angst vor spinnen hat oder so was
hierzulande die tun nichts ist ändert
aber nichts daran dass menschen ändert
nichts daran dass viele menschen angst
vor spinnen haben das würde man jetzt
technisch als neurotische angst
bezeichnen es gibt real ängste also dass
sich vor allem heraus heranrauschenden
auto.de mich kaum noch ausweichen kann
angst haben ist eine reale angst und
diese auch ausgesprochen sinnvoll weil
sie mich veranlasst zur seite zu
springen so und hier haben wir hier
haben wir eine pandemie und es ist
absolut sinnvoll davor angst zu haben
also das wäre ja das kontraproduktiv so
was man sich vorstellen kann wenn es
alle sagen ja na ja und das macht mir ja
nix das trifft mich kann mich ja nicht
treffen und so das könnte ja eine
reaktion sein aber die menschen haben
angst deswegen ich meine begriffe allein
die ansteckung ausbreitung in fett
das sind ja alles auch so
begrifflichkeiten bei denen fühlt man
sich ja nicht wohin vertiefen wird
und wenn man darüber nachdenkt und
insofern ist es also eine völlig völlig
angemessener angst die man da hat und
dann variiert sie natürlich zwischen den
unterschiedlichen alters und betroffenen
gruppen klar
auch das wäre realistisch aber da muss
ich sagen das ist auch im moment nicht
hysterisch ich hab nicht also vielleicht
kann ich das nur sagen weil ich mich
niemals in sozialen netzwerken aufhalten
um einigermaßen normal durch die welt zu
laufen ich nehme an da ist viel hysterie
unterwegs und falschmeldung und quatsch
aber generell würde ich sagen wir leben
noch in einem sehr und historischen
alltag und das finde ich eigentlich
super also ich würd vielleicht was die
rolle der sozialen netzwerke angeht auch
eine lanze dafür brechen das gerade sehr
viele menschen gibt die die sozialen
netzwerke nutzen um hilfsangebote dass
wir machen an ihre gemeinschaft vor ort
an die nachbarschaft es gibt eine sehr
breite durch neigung gerade
kinderbetreuung die sich auch dafür
einsetzen solche falschmeldungen sowas
entgegenzutreten also leider kursieren
ja sprachnachrichten bayreuth wo über
irgendwelche medikamente gesprochen wird
die angebliche wirkung haben auf die
verbreitung des virus dass es sich dabei
um eine falschmeldung handelt und dass
man dem auch aktiv entgegentreten
sondern ich habe das dann auch gemacht
in den vielen ortsgruppen in dem man so
ist das verdanke ich den sozialen medien
also wir haben natürlich in den sozialen
medien ein hohes maß an falschmeldung
aber wenn man damit ein bisschen im
inkompetenz ran geht dann haben wir
gerade heute über die sozialen medien
auch die chance informationen über das
virus und über die verbreitung und über
die gegenmaßnahmen zu verbreiten also so
schlimm es auf der einen seite ist kann
es auf der anderen seite auch nutzen hat
was man im netz im moment auch viel
sieht sind fotos von leeren regalen in
lebensmittelgeschäften eine eine
vielleicht irrationale reaktion der
menschen ist dass sie haben es dann dass
sie auf einmal nudeln reis und
toilettenpapier einkaufen in mengen die
sie wahrscheinlich in den nächsten
anderthalb jahren kaum verbrauchen
können ist das eine überreaktion
also ich glaube es ist schon wichtig die
leute darauf hinzuweisen dass die
nach schübel im bereich der
nahrungsmittelversorgung gesichert sind
und dass wenn die regale am freitag leer
gekauft sind dass er am montag wieder
voll sind und dass sie sich deswegen
keine sorgen machen brauchen ich finde
es aber auch ein stückweit verständlich
dass menschen angst haben und sagen ich
gehe jetzt los und kaufte mir was damit
ich möglicherweise zu hause ein paar
tage ein paar wochen über die runden
komme es sollte noch nicht ausarten in
panikkäufe bei denen man dann denjenigen
die beispielsweise desinfektionsmittel
professionell benutzen das vor der nase
weg kauft und das dann durch profis
nicht mehr verwendet werden kann
das haben sie in sogenannten
katastrophen not plänen wird ja sogar
explizit gesagt dass man sich bevorraten
soll an der einen oder anderen stelle
genau wir haben natürlich nicht eine
situation wo jetzt ab morgen sozusagen
diese katastrophen von nuclear schon
gelten sondern man natürlich immer sagen
muss wir wissen nicht was morgen was
über ort morgen für massnahmen
angeordnet werden man kann es nicht
sagen und diese unsicherheit diese große
frage die viele einfach haben die leute
einkäufe tätigen die führt glaube ich
dazu dass jeder noch ein bisschen mehr
einkauft ich glaube es ist auch ein
stück weit ein popkulturelles phänomen
dass die leute da solche verlängern
regale fotografieren ins internet
stellen also vielleicht sollte man das
auch nicht überbewerten
kulartz gerade angesprochen es gibt
natürlich auch solche sachen des
menschen einfach das letzte
desinfektionsmittel noch noch kaufen
obwohl es professionell viel dringender
gebraucht wird wir hatten meldungen dass
in krankenhäusern mundschutze geklaut
wurden und auch desinfektionsmittel auf
werden sogar von intensivstationen
wie groß ist der egoismus in so einer
situation von dem ein oder anderen eben
aus dieser angst heraus dass er nicht
genau weiß was auf ihn zukommt
wahrscheinlich nicht größer als im
normalzustand der gesellschaft auch es
gibt halt menschen die verhalten sich
als sozial oder die verhalten sich
kriminell
die versuchung zu betrügen es gibt ja
dieses phänomen habe ich gelesen dass
jetzt
erst den trickbetrug gibt bei alten
menschen anzurufen und zu sagen ich bin
der enkel und ich bin infiziert und ich
brauch jetzt geld aber das gibt es unter
normalbedingungen auch nur hier sieht
man dann unter veränderten bedingungen
fällt es einem noch extremer auf also
etwas niedrigeres als
desinfektionsmittel auf einer
kinderkrebsstation zu klauen kann man
sich kaum vorstellen aber trotzdem würde
ich sagen das ist ein ausdruck von von
verhältnissen wie sind unter normalen
bedingungen auch so da sind und auch
hier würde ich wiederum sagen wir
beobachten ja eigentlich jetzt noch
überhaupt nichts auffälliges
ganz im gegenteil also wir sehen ja habe
ich so das gefühl gerade in einer stadt
wie berlin eine unglaubliche entleerung
und verringerung von geschwindigkeit zu
beschleunigen
und ich habe auch nicht den eindruck
dass die leute die unterwegs sind in
irgendeiner weise besonders angst
getrieben oder panisch oder sowas sind
es sind einfach weniger unterwegs die
ganze geschwindigkeit verlangsamt sich
weil weniger da sind auch auf im
autoverkehr scheint die aggression
geringer zu sein also alles das was die
was den alltag so hektisch macht und die
leute unter stress setzt das wird gerade
runter gefahren
das ist ja eigentlich auch noch mal
interessant als phänomen vielleicht
passt das dann auch zu den späteren
lerngeschichten dass man sagt wir
brauchen ja diese ganze hyper stress und
aggressions kultur überhaupt nicht
schauen wir auf die medien her coole
welche rolle spielt die medien in dieser
situation es ist ja manchmal ein
schmaler grat zwischen panikmache und
bagatellisierung wo stehen die medien da
dass wir vielleicht noch sagen ich
glaube schon dass diese krise bestimmte
chancen bietet und ja es gibt ein
gewisses maß an entschleunigung man kann
sich bestimmte fragen stellen man kann
darüber nachdenken man kann reflektieren
aber das gilt natürlich nur für
diejenigen die sich das leisten können
für diejenigen die heute im
gesundheitssystem tätig sind ist
sozusagen das gegenteil von
entschleunigung der fall
deswegen will ich muss sagen ich finde
wir sollten ein bisschen aufpassen dass
wir das ist im factory jetzt so ein
bisschen der fall
diese krise auch nicht glorifizieren das
ist jetzt das moment des radierens und
das nachdenkst auf das wir alle gewartet
haben jetzt können wir uns endlich mal
in ruhe gedanken machen und ein buch
lesen das können bestimmte leute mit
dickem portemonnaie machen die auch mal
home office machen können oder
vielleicht auch gar kein office machen
müssen aber für die leute im
gesundheitssystem oder menschen die jobs
haben die wichtig sind für das
funktionieren der gesellschaft gibt das
nicht da ist gerade das gegenteil von
entschleunigung der fall
und deswegen war nicht so ein bisschen
davor diese krise zu glorifizieren
mit blick auf die medien glaube ich auf
der einen seite haben wir die riesige
chance dass menschen viel mehr und viel
mehr sich informieren können
wir erleben dass der chefgeologe hier
von der charité
herr professor drosten ein gefeierter
podcast star ist ja jetzt schon 14
folgen heute ist die vierzehnte folge
online gegangen und viele menschen
können partizipieren an den
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen also
dank der medien haben viel mehr menschen
die möglichkeit dem ganzen zu folgen und
auf der anderen seite gibt es aber
natürlich auch das große risiko das
falsche information weitergetragen
werden umso wichtiger ist es dass wir
ein filtern erleben von informationen
die wichtig sind die relevant sind für
die bewältigung der krise und auf der
anderen seite panikmache die wir im
rahmen nicht gebrauchen können
haben sie ihren medien verhalten
verändert sein reim nein ich habe meinen
medienverhalten es so reduziert und
klassisch das ist das kann ich gar nicht
gravierend verändern
ich wollte aber zu den medien thema
nochmal dazu sagen es ist wie ich
beobachte ein problem was man an anderen
sachverhalten auch sehen kann
es gibt gerade in talkshows so ein motto
das die anwesenden leute aus der politik
gewissermaßen schon immer auf das
nächste thema verpflichtet werden also
ihr habt der wird gerade gesagt werden
jetzt die und die maßnahme und dann wird
gefragt warum kommt denn nicht die
andere oder sowas in der art ja und das
ist ungut das ist ungut ich würde im
moment zb ist ganz gerne sehen und dass
man den talkshow motors auch verändert
und sagt jetzt machen wir mal sortier
vorgang ja wenn da jetzt leute aus der
bundesregierung
oder aus landesregierung dass man sich
erst mal noch einmal genau erklären
lässt warum die jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt dieser entscheidung getroffen
haben und dann das überhaupt einmal zur
kenntnis nimmt und vielleicht auch dass
es auch in ihrem sinne mit den leuten
die jetzt ihren job machen in den
krankenhäusern und in den verwaltungen
und so weiter einfach auch mal in
anderen motto schaltet und mai betont
dass wir in einem land leben wo
unfassbar viel total gut läuft obwohl
krise
und da sind auch die medien in der
verantwortung
diesen diesen anderen modus auch mal
einzuschalten und sozusagen geht es wenn
man mal mit dem jahr aber journalismus
auf so nenne ich das das egal was man
sagt dann kommen immer ja aber sondern
dass man sagt ja okay was wären denn
jetzt noch geeignete strategien oder wie
auch immer es ist man gewissermaßen
etwas anders auch in das gespräch kommt
und mal mit dem mit dem problematisieren
und skandalisieren und was kommt als
nächstes und welche maßnahmen und wann
werden wir denn das richtet sich jetzt
gar nicht gegen sie wir reden ja
gewissermaßen hier so in einem suchenden
modus auch und ich glaube das ist
eigentlich gut in so einer situation
dass auch man nicht tut als gäbe es
jetzt leute abgesehen von herrn ross
vielleicht die wirklich ganz genau
wissen wovon sie reden weil wir sind
alle konfrontiert mit einer neuen
situation insofern gibt es für so eine
situation jetzt außer virologen
eigentlich gar keine expertinnen und
experten
wir sind jetzt alle immer lärmsituation
und das finde ich müsste sich auch in
einem gewissen medialen stil übersetzen
legte kurz anhalten darf ich glaube es
ist ganz wesentlich dass wir die chance
haben dass politiker und menschen in der
verwaltung um dieser situation die
chance haben auch mal zu sagen dass sie
etwas bestimmtes noch nicht wissen
sondern dass sie einen bestimmten
zeitraum brauchen um eine politische
entscheidung zu treffen wären wir ganz
oft die situation dass gefragt wird
warum trefft ihr eigentlich diese eine
richtige entscheidung die wir jetzt von
euch erwarten ihr müsst das eigentlich
machen und wir erleben dann das
wissenschaftliche erwartung oder das
inhaltliche fragen vermischt
mit der politischen entscheidung darüber
was man selber richtig findet oder
falsch und wir haben jetzt die chance
uns zu überlegen welchen
unterschiedlichen stimmungen welchen
unterschiedlichen meinungen man glauben
schenkt die einbezieht in einen
willensbildungsprozess und dann als
politik auch mal sagt also wir müssen
hier vielleicht noch ein bisschen
darüber nachdenken was richtig ist und
was man an dieser stelle tun sollte
insofern glaube ich dass auch ist das
tatsächlich eine chance um über den
modus von politischer willensbildung
nachzudenken
ja und auch ein stück weit über die
transparenz nachzudenken wie wichtig ist
transparenz an dieser stelle wenn wir
auch nach china schauen wo das ganze
jahr angefangen hat am anfang hat man ja
nicht so transparent darüber gesprochen
dann war es aber doch durchaus
transparent und hat sehr drastischen
maßnahmen dann auch durchgesetzt ist das
einfacher eigentlich in der totalitären
regime als in einer demokratie
ich glaube transparenz ist der
entscheidende unterschied an dem sich
entscheiden wird ob eine totalitäre
gesellschaft ein totalitäres start
system besser in der lage ist mit so
etwas umzugehen oder einer demokratie
wenn ich versuche das sehen wir gerade
im iran wesentliche teile der
bevölkerung auszuschließen von der
information über ein virus von der frage
was sind eigentlich ansteckungswege was
sollte man tun was sollte man
unterlassen sollte man die heiligen
stätten schließen oder sollte man
menschen weiter dahin schicken damit sie
sich möglicherweise sogar anstecken
dann können wir erleben dass ein
transparent geführt es demokratisches
staatswesen er in der lage ist eine
wöchentliche herr zu werden und das war
natürlich gerade im vergleich mit china
auch sicherstellen müssen dass wir
diesen systemen wird über diese krise
hinaus auch als eine aufgabe für uns
begreifen also klar kann ein totalitärer
geführtes staatswesen viel schneller in
shutter und machen so und sagen es ist
schluss wir werden aber erleben dass ein
langfristiger eine langfristige
bekämpfung einer solchen krise also die
das durchhalten von bestimmten
hygienemaßnahmen über viele wochen und
monate nur getragen werden kann wenn es
in der bevölkerung legitimiert ist und
legitimation hängt ein stück weiter
daran dass die leute verstehen warum sie
das machen müssen und das hat dann
wieder mit transparenz zu tun also wenn
politiker mehr darüber sprechen mit
welchem wissenschaftler sie wann darüber
gesprochen haben welche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
dann hilft dass solche maßnahmen zu
verankern ich finde es zum beispiel sehr
hilfreich dass
wieder herr professor osten sagt dass er
bestimmte politiker über das thema
schulschließung zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt gebrieft und die aber dann
zwei drei tage darüber nachgedacht haben
erst zu tun und dass er das nicht für
einen fehler hält sondern da ist erst
ausdrücklich für erforderlich hält 23
tage darüber nachzudenken wie man
schulschließungen eigentlich organisiert
damit nicht am ende die
krankenschwestern zu hause bleiben weil
sie ihre kinder betreuen müssen also man
muss muss was durchdenken und bestimmte
dilemmata in die öffentlichkeit zu
tragen als entscheidungs person
das ist ein zeichen von selbstreflexion
das demokratische systeme stärker macht
als totalitäre systeme und deswegen
können wir auch da als demokratische
systeme gewinnen gewinnen er sich gerne
auf die ökonomische situation schauen
in der jetzigen situation würden sie
sagen weil es ja ein weltweites phänomen
ist was diesen virus betrifft dass es
auch die schwäche des wirtschaftlichen
systems zeigt stichwort lieferketten
also viele dinge die in china produziert
wurden können nicht weiter geliefert
werden und dinge des täglichen lebens
können nicht nicht geliefert werden
naja das ist eine entzauberung der
globalisierung von der wir gelernt haben
über mehrere jahrzehnte sie zu feiern
als das allein seligmachende und jetzt
zeigt sich dass mit der verlängerung der
lieferketten und der
wertschöpfungsketten natürlich eine
höhere verlässlichkeit entsteht und wir
können es ja dann durchmustern an den
einzelnen phänomenen die jetzt deutlich
werden also dass das arzneimittel gibt
die werden nur von einem hersteller am
anderen ende der welt produziert und man
muss sich darauf verlassen dass das
nicht unterbrochen wird und insofern
haben wir hier wieder den effekt dass
eine solche dass dieses virus ja
eigentlich probleme offen legt die wir
sowieso schon haben wir uns ganz ähnlich
wie mit dem mit dem was sie zu recht
thematisiert haben die leute die den
laden zusammenhalten so nenne ich die
immer in den pflegeberufen bei der
polizei und so weiter wir können wir uns
ja nun über lange lange lange zeit
zurück erinnern in denen man versucht
hat diese situation zu problematisieren
dass die leute zu schlecht bezahlt
werden dass sie zu schlechter aber
bedingungen haben dass wir krankenhäuser
privatisieren mit entsprechenden folgen
und so weiter und so weiter
und insofern liegt eigentlich das ist
überhaupt das wesen fast jeder krise die
liegt eigentlich etwas offen was
ansonsten auch der fall ist aber
gewissermaßen in der normalen flughöhen
nicht gesehen wird weil es den anschein
hat das meiste funktioniert ja ganz gut
herr berger sprach gerade von der
entzauberung der globalisierung ist das
jetzt nur notwendigkeit in dieser krise
vielleicht mal über unser
wirtschaftssystem und
gesellschaftssystem nachzudenken also
ich finde wir sollten nicht die falschen
schlüsse ziehen wir können ja sehen dass
gerade beim thema impfstoffe
weiterentwicklung weitertragen
wissenschaftlicher erkenntnisse wir
gerade durch die globalisierung ein fast
schon weltweiten diskurs im
wissenschaftlichen bereich darüber haben
was wir erst einmal grundrenoviert ist
jetzt ja abstiegssaison schiffes ist
doch durch digitalisierung und andere
themen viel globaler geworden viel
schneller geworden viel interdependenz
miteinander sind jetzt schon immer
gelobt weil ich sie brauchen wissen das
wissen schaffen es ist ein wesentlicher
punkt und ich will auch sagen also
natürlich hat diese krise maschinen
massive wirtschaftliche auswirkungen
wären dass in deutschland alles noch
erleben wir sehen es jetzt am dax
gesehen dass an den an der an der
drohenden pleite von vielen
selbstständigen von vielen unternehmen
die jetzt wirklich vor dem nichts stehen
und großes problem haben und dann zu
sagen also unser wachstums getriebenes
wirtschaft und die globalisierung ist
alles über bord werfen
wir haben gesagt dieser menschen
versuchen sollten verstehen sich jetzt
alles zu schnell das hat niemand gesagt
hat nicht gesagt über bord werfen ich
bin nicht naiv wir können nicht ein
komplettes wirtschaftssystem über bord
werfen
sie habe nur gesagt es werden dinge
sichtbar die man in der oberflächlichen
betrachtung ansonsten gerne wegschiebt
und dass wir erhöhungen von
verletzlichkeiten haben das werden sie
nicht negieren können ist eine frage wie
gehe ich mit diesen verletzlichkeiten
umgekommen hinstellen und sagen ja no
risk no fun
wir wollen so eine form von wirtschaft
haben dann gehen wir dieses risiko eben
ein aber dann ist diese krise auch
anders darüber zu diskutieren
und nochmal zu dem anderen thema zurück
es ist ja nicht alles 1
wensin teilsystem angucken wie die
wissenschaft die ja schon immer
internationalisiert deshalb geht man in
humboldt ausstellung und guckt sich an
wie die internationalisiert gewesen ist
schon vor langer zeit das ist ja was
ganz anderes als wenn ich sozusagen
weltweit dasselbe wirtschaftssystem mit
denselben parametern etablieren und
insofern muss man glaube ich an vielen
stellen gucken wo funktioniert was das
kommunikation global funktioniert ist ja
nicht dieselbe aussage wie das weiß weiß
ich das produzieren von t shirts in
malaysia super gut funktioniert
geschweige denn arzneimittel also da
muss man schon das hängt dann auch
hingucken er kollegen verletzlichkeiten
offenlegen und bin ich sofort dabei
darüber reden wir können wir im
krisenmodus dafür sorgen dass hier noch
der selektions mittel ist und noch
mundschutz auf jeden fall aber die
einbeziehung von staaten ausstellen
ländern in globale wertschöpfungsketten
hat auch dazu beigetragen dort die
absolute armut signifikant zu verhindern
das ist klar ist es sozusagen ist das
eine oder das andere aber wir können
gerne wie verletzlichkeiten sprechen und
darüber sprechen wie kann man sozusagen
widerstandsfähiger werden als
wirtschaftssystem aber nach jesus
wirtschaftssystem so wie es ist hat in
seiner art der wachstums getriebenheit
und auch der globalisierung viele
menschen aus der armut geholt die sonst
nicht herausgekommen werden das darf man
auch über diese krise nicht vergessen es
auch gegenbeispiele aber ich würde gerne
noch mal ein wenig auf deutschland
schauen sie haben eben die solo
selbstständigen angesprochen
die bundesregierung hat kurzarbeitergeld
hat auch kredite und all diese dinge in
aussicht gestellt oder auch schon auf
den weg gebracht aber für die solo
selbstständigen ist es ja vielfach
insofern eine schwierige situation weil
sie vor ihre existenz weil sie
existenzbedrohlichen situationen stehen
und gar nicht wissen wie sie da wieder
rauskommen sollen kredit hilft da auch
nicht unbedingt etwas wäre da zum
beispiel ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen nicht eine möglichkeit
diesen menschen zumindest übergangsweise
für ein paar monaten zu helfen also das
ganz wichtig dass kurzarbeiter geld
hilft natürlich überhaupt nicht weiter
wenn man selbstständig ist und deswegen
brauchen wir darüber hinaus auch eine
abschaffung der vor fälligkeit von
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen wir müssen
noch mal neu über das thema
steuerstundungen reden also da müssen
eine ganze menge entlastungen kommen und
es stimmt das muss auch geld fließen
also die leute müssen merken es gibt
hier eine unterstützung das kann eine
form der liquiditätshilfe sondern es
kann auch eine nothilfe sein die man
jetzt schnell
unbürokratisch überweist ich glaube aber
nicht dass wir in der lage sind das
ganze unbürokratisch zu machen denn wir
jetzt eine reform des sozialstaats
machen und sagen wir für ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen ein ich
weiß dass diejenigen die ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen wollen
bei jeder krise sei es klimawandel sei
es veränderung der arbeitswelt oder sein
dass digitalisierung der auffassung sind
wenn das kommt sind alle krisen gelöst
ich glaube ist nicht ich glaube nicht
dass wir jetzt die zeit haben um das
einzuführen damit grundsätzlich nicht
einzuführen aber vielleicht für
bestimmte berufsgruppen oder zum
beispiel für die solo selbstständigen
für eine bestimmte zeit
es entspricht nicht so vielleicht ganz
anders nennen vielleicht muss man es
nothilfefonds nennen oder sich nur hilfe
von klingt schonmal gut auf jeden fall
die frage ist welches menschenbild haben
wir und da sind ganz viele leute die
haben das gefühl dass sie eine leistung
erbringen die etwas wert ist die diese
leistung erbringen wollen und jetzt war
die leistung nicht mehr nachgefragt wird
weil es keine veranstaltungen gibt
beispielsweise auf die man auf der man
als moderator oder als maskenbildnerin
tätig sein kann
die das nicht mehr machen können und
deswegen sollte man kurzfristig sehen
dass man diese lücke überbrückt aber ich
weiß nicht auf diesen menschen wirklich
geholfen ist wenn man sagt ihr habt ihr
geld oder geschäftsmodell okay aber wir
geben uns jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
geld und dann seid ihr ruhig gestellt es
geht darum diese krise zu überbrücken
aber jetzt das gesamte geschäftsmodell
dieser menschen in frage zu stellen und
zu sagen und es lohnt sich das ja
sowieso nicht was du machst deswegen
brauchen wir bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen das sehe ich anders
zum schluss der sendung würde ich gerne
darauf einen aspekt eingehen stichwort
nationalismus wir wissen von der
amerikanischen regierung von präsident
trump dass er sich durchaus bemüht hat
einen impfstoff oder zumindest
diejenigen die kurz davor sind ihnen zu
entwickeln nach amerika zu holen ist
dass die zeit wo nationale egoismen sich
den weg bahnen und greifen
na hoffentlich nicht aber ich würde
sagen wir sehen hier die negativen
auswirkungen das wieder der der
wiederkehr des nationalismus in den
politischen diskurs das ist das große
problem mir leuchtet zum beispiel auch
nicht ein
die grenzschließung von polen tschechien
jetzt heute ungarn ja das ist ja nur
ausdrucksform sozusagen eines eines
phantasma das virus sich gewissermaßen
an grenzen hält und es ist ja auch
ausdruck eines versprechens dann dieser
starken männer zu sagen ich schütze das
volk indem ich die grenze zu machen das
ist natürlich gerade in europa von trump
brauchen wir nicht zu reden das ist
sozusagen ein phänomen ganz eigener art
das ist in europa natürlich wirklich ein
rückfall den man nur erklären kann
dadurch dass wir die letzten jahre eben
beobachten mussten des nationalismus zu
einer politischen kategorie wieder
geworden ist und hier hätte vorhin als
wir so positiv im grunde genommen
versucht haben zu sammeln würde ich ja
auch sagen dass das eigentlich ein
zeichen es gewesen wäre für ein
positives handeln wenn das europa bbs
emphatisch verstehen auch in dieser
krisensituation zu einem gemeinsamen
handeln wirklich kommen würde und das
ist dadurch natürlich unterminiert das
finde ich so und dann hat man noch nicht
an der stelle in gefahr
ja also warum können der französische
innenminister und der deutsche
innenminister nicht in einer gemeinsamen
video konferenz bekannt geben wie das
deutsch polnische grenzregion aussieht
stattdessen erzählt man ja wir haben das
vorher abgestimmt und dann kommt einen
tag später raus die franzosen sind
überhaupt nicht einverstanden das ist
wirklich ein armutszeugnis wenigstens
deutschland und frankreich müssen in
dieser situation gemeinsam agieren
wenigstens beim thema das ist die
zerreißprobe für unsere gesellschaft die
zerreißprobe
ich glaube nicht groß aber ich bin
optimistisch weil viele menschen sich
sehr verantwortungsbewusst verhalten und
weil wir beobachten können dass sie sehr
genau wissen dass es jetzt auf das
verhalten jedes einzelnen ankommt um
risikogruppen zu schützen ist das nur
zerreißprobe chance nein also ich glaube
ich glaube nicht dass das zerreißen wird
ich glaube dass man die wirtschaftlichen
folgen im augenblick sehr sehr schwer
abschätzen kann
und da müssen wir darüber nachdenken was
sind dann die folgewirkung also wenn wir
eine rückkehr von massenarbeitslosigkeit
haben und ganz andere dinge
da müssen wir neu diskutieren ja dann
dann so eine krise ist ja nicht etwas wo
sich gewissermaßen eine variable so und
so verhält sondern alles das und das ist
wiederum das was moderne gesellschaften
auszeichnen es hängt unheimlich viel
immer mit dieser ein variable zusammen
und deshalb können wir zum zeitpunkt iks
also heute auch nicht sagen wie sie die
ökonomische situation in drei monaten da
raus und das bedeutet das für das
sozialsystem was bedeutet das für den
arbeitsmarkt usw usw
also vielleicht kann man kann man auch
sagen das ist wunsch nach kontrolle und
die kontrolle können wir jetzt leider
gar nicht liefern
ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich für diese
angeregte diskussion und ich bedanke
mich bei ihnen sehr hat sich fürs
zuschauen
das war unter den linden wir haben
gesprochen über unseren
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt in der
situation der krise bleiben sie phoenix
gewogen wir informieren sie in all
unseren sendungen vor allen dingen in
den pressekonferenzen aber auch den
gesprächssendung und sonstigen
ereignissen über den fortgang die das
virus uns beschert und damit wünsche ich
ihnen noch einen schönen dank bei
phoenix
[Musik]